Dana Look-Arimoto thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Great. Thank you for asking.
It's been quite a whirlwind, 2020.
We were supposed to do this last week
when the fires broke out in California.
So, just as we thought we've seen it all,
it looks like
there's a little bit more coming.
But  we're doing it.
So, I'm very thankful
for being so generous with your time
and for being so flexible.
Sure.
To start off, you have four dogs.
Among them, 15 legs,
only three of them can hear.
Tell me a little bit
about your rescue dogs.
Well, they're rescue.
So, like all of us,
they are differently abled.
One has three legs, one can't hear.
And we love them all.
I love it. What are their names?
Leo, Leilani, Scooter and Lily.
Oh, I love it. Very very cute.
Wonderful. Okay.
So, Dana, before we get to talk
about some of the topics that we discussed
that I think are going to be fascinating,
whether it's about gender equality
or work-life balance,
I'd love to hear a little bit
about your journey because you've done
so many different things
from being in advisory boards,
to creating organizations,
to now coaching leadership
to different leaders
and leadership styles
to speaking engagements.
So, who are you?
And what motivates you?
I am clearly someone with ADD
and someone who likes to experiment.
And I'm definitely motivated and inspired
by making an impact on the world.
And so, in a lot of ways,
having hired and trained, develop,
mentored thousands of people
over 20 some years,
primarily in Silicon Valley,
I feel like I can honestly say,
I have made a difference, however,
I have a real impatience for action,
which is also very Silicon Valley.
And so, I would like to help
more people universally.
And that's the mission I'm on now.
What is that?
So, what does that even mean,
that you're coaching and helping people,
whether it's in Silicon Valley
or elsewhere, but what does that mean
for you to help make an impact
by helping others?
Yeah. So, one of the reasons
I dabble in so many
different methods and mediums,
having a book now and a podcast;
and posting on Instagram;
and having a full executive
coaching practice
with C-Suite members
of different kinds of companies,
including founder led companies,
it gives me a chance to really work
in different ways with different people.
Some short term, some long term,
some quick hit,
some really over horizon work
and strategy, so I have
all these different vantage points
of working with individuals
and helping them
with where they want to go.
So, you're looking at all these
hundreds or thousands of people
that you're saying,
"Give me some things that often come up?"
What are some things that oftentimes
you see pattern recognition
and you're saying,
ah, I've seen this before;
I'm seeing this type of behavior;
I'm seeing this type of thing
that maybe if I look at that case study,
I can bring that in and help?
For sure. So, people confuse
management with leadership
every single day.
And there's a clear
and distinct difference,
and I'm really interested
in helping people with leadership
whether they're the leader of their life;
the leader at work;
the leader in their marriage;
the leader in their career;
they're leader in their education;
I really am interested
in helping people lead.
And so, you've mentioned that book
that you've written.
So, tell me a little bit about that
and how that ties into this work
with mentorship and coaching.
Yeah. So, I hit my head pretty hard
many times, and I guess I'm a slow learner
in terms of work-life balance
and believing I can have it all
by doing it all, all at one time.
And of course, women in particular,
in Silicon Valley,
we have all these great muses
who make it look like that's possible.
Well, the truth is, it's not.
We actually all have limits.
And without serious help,
serious outsourcing,
serious financial wherewithal, etc, etc,
it's really not possible to have it all
all at one time.
And so, what I've really learned
and proven over time
and now I'm helping others
to figure out for themselves
and their organizations is that
you have to give something up
to get what it is you really want.
And most people don't even ask themselves,
what is it I really want
situationally and relatively.
Right. So, I mean, when every time,
like we say, work life-balance,
immediately, the 21st century
has given rise to this idea
of work life-balance.
And a lot of different people
are talking about it.
Throughout high school,
the mantra that my principal had
was balance, balance, balance.
Everybody's talking about balance.
As a go getter myself,
I can justify there's 24 hours in a day,
sometimes I feel like any minute
that I'm doing something,
I feel like I'm missing out
on that other thing.
Talk to me a little bit about your take
on this work-life balance.
What does it take to really succeed?
And what does it mean
to be authentic enough with yourself
to be able to forgo some other things
that maybe the social norm
won't really let you?
Yeah. So, the social norm
is a big part of it.
I'm glad you brought that up.
So, there's these should:
you should do this,
you shouldn't do that.
And someone also might be
someone you emulate or your muse
or you're a role model or your mentor
and you think,
"Oh, they do it this way,
so, I should too."
Well, one size never fits all.
One size only fits one.
So, there's five key areas of life
that we all share universally
and they are:
career, family, friendships,
community and your own well-being.
And so, what happens
when you're constantly running
like a hamster,
sprinting inside of a marathon
in this wheel, on this teeter totter,
you might hit balance for a moment,
but it comes with a really high cost.
And then you're usually depleted,
exhausted, sick in some cases,
like I talk about in my book,
and you roll out of the wheel
and then you hit reset
and you get right back in the wheel.
We don't do anything different.
And then, you just start running.
It sounds like you were alluding
to some specific example
that I'd love to hear.
Sure. I used to get pneumonia
one to three times per year.
Pneumonia, one to three times per year.
Yeah. Like clockwork.
Really?
Pattern recognition.
Predictably, I would know
it was coming and still working.
So, it was seasonal
based on how much work you had.
Yeah.
And so, okay.
So, tell me about this experience.
You are getting pneumonia seasonally
two or three times a year,
you realize that it's part of your work,
I'm guessing that
you are still working very hard.
You're allowing yourself
to get pneumonia
for quite some time, right?
Yes. Years. Years and years.
It's like this total type-A overachiever.
Single mom at the time,
really thought I was striving
for something, not realizing,
and it's a little corny,
but it is the journey
it's not the destination.
And if you are someone
who's very motivated, very high achieving,
you know there's no destination.
Because there's another mountain
to climb anyway.
Right.
And no one says,
"Let me sprint the marathon."
and then they win.
100%. I remember vividly my family
and we were climbing
Mount Kilimanjaro last year
and it was one of the hardest things
I've ever done in my life.
And as we reach the peak,
we were telling ourselves
the entire eight days,
"There's no way we're ever doing
this thing again."
"This is awful."
"We're in so much pain."
The second we hit the bus down
at the bottom of the mountain, we're like,
"Okay. So, Everest next year?"
like, what's happening?
So, covid hit.
So, maybe that's one of the reasons
why we didn't go for that.
But I can totally feel what you're saying.
So, now that you're helping others
understand this through the book,
what are you saying then?
So, what is the solution?
Because I know for myself
I will not be satisfied if I do less work.
All things are not created equal.
So, what I suggest is that
you actually choose
what you want to work on,
what you want to spend time on.
And the derivative,
the delta of the equation
is joy, productivity and value.
So, if I say to you,
you can have all three,
that's your triple threat,
joy, productivity and value.
But you can't do all things equally
at all times on any given day,
especially inside of a week.
I really encourage you to look
at your week's production,
168 hours in a week.
We all have the same amount of time.
You can't buy more,
then you might think differently about,
Okay, do I want to spend
more time in career,
more time with family,
are career and family my top,
and then I'm willing
to trade off a little bit
on community and maybe friendships.
But what about your wellbeing?
What about you
and taking care of yourself?
Because when we come last,
there's nothing to give.
Right. Right.
So then, I mean, these are definitely
not things that we can do alone, right?
I mean, I don't think that I could
really be honest with myself sitting down
because there's so many different pulls
and so many different things
that bring you into a different area.
So how do people go about that?
So, I have a free quiz
on settlesmarter.com/quiz,
and it gives you at least a very quick,
very simple five minutes or less baseline
as to where you are when
when no one else is looking.
So, you take this quiz.
It can be anonymous.
It doesn't have to be,
but it's not going to get shared
with anyone but yourself.
And so, depending on how explicit you are
with yourself, you figure out
where am I actually spending time
versus where do I really want
to spend time.
So, the quiz forces you to make decisions
and trade offs and then it gives you
a little bit of like a spider graph
of where you're at
versus where you want to be at.
And then there's some tips and tricks
and tools and traps to avoid
on how to get there.
Definitely.
So, what patterns have you been seeing,
at least with the work that you're doing
in terms of people's ability
to find his balance
or if it's helping their work
or it's hindering the work?
Because obviously,
there's so much connectivity here
with their inner well-being,
their physical health,
with the work they're doing.
How does it all come together?
Yeah. I like to say harmony
beats balance every time,
and harmony is what you get
when you integrate.
It's when we compartmentalize
or separate ourselves
or pretend we're one person at one work
and one person at home.
And especially in covid,
we all see everyone all the time.
It's not like I don't see your kitchen
behind you right now, I do.
And it's not like you don't see my son
that I forgot to put away.
And if you saw a little lower my camera,
you'd be like,
"Oh, your credentials are on the ground."
Well, that's because my social media,
I'd take them off the wall
and I have flowers,
but I wouldn't normally have flowers.
So, we're just revealed
we're just ourselves.
We're just human.
And so when we stop
compartmentalizing so much
and we start making
those conscious trade offs,
things start to really shift for us
and we can really feel that joy,
productivity and value.
So, now you were saying
like we're entering new reality
of where it's not even work-life balance,
but the line between life and work
is so blurred that in one moment,
I'm sitting here and like you said,
if we look at the camera
a little bit there,
I have my dog sitting right next to me.
And It's playtime in about five minutes
when this is over.
So, how do we balance this whole arena?
We talk about it.
And I would say to you,
"What are you going to play
with your dog?"
"Oh, I'd love to see your dog."
And you say,
"Oh, can you bring
your four dogs in here?"
Probably not, because it'd be total chaos.
But I mean, even on social media,
I'm starting to put my dogs
in the shot with me
because why not let people
really see who I am and what I care about.
And that's where rapport building
and mirroring an alignment
and fully understand each other comes from
is finding something of commonality.
This is what the number one thing
is in dealing with gender issues,
with dealing with diversity,
equity and inclusion issues,
find something in common.
Like if you were wearing glasses right now
and I'm wearing glasses right now,
we could say we both have glasses.
Who cares that you're younger than I am,
and a guy.
And I'm older than you are, and a woman.
Who cares?
We both have glasses.
You don't have glasses.
So, that fell apart there,
but you know what I mean.
Not yet. It's going to happen
sooner rather than later.
But you're mentioning
gender equality or inequality
and diversification.
Give me your two cents
on both those subjects.
First, seek to understand
before seeking to be understood.
That's it. It solves everything.
Clarify a little bit.
What do you mean by that?
Have you heard of the Golden Rule?
I have.
And I've heard of the platinum rule,
which I believe you're going to allude to.
Right?
I thought I invented the platinum rule.
I can't prove it.
But I put that into place
in my company in 1999.
And you were probably
way better at research than I am.
So, I'm going to actually ask you
to trade me this back and tell me,
did that come out before '99?
If not, I missed the boat.
I should have coined that.
Yeah, go ahead.
No no. What is the golden rule
and the platinum rule?
The golden rule,
which comes apparently from the Bible,
I'm spiritual, not religious, however,
the golden rule is:
Do unto others
as you'd have done unto you.
The platinum rule is:
Do unto others
as they'd have done onto them.
If you don't know what somebody wants,
you need to understand it,
before you try to get them
to see it your way.
And because we're talking Silicon Valley
and everything agile,
I will add the equation for speed
and enhancement of performance is:
One plus one equals three.
That's the collaborative model which is
your ideas and experience and mine together
are moving us further faster.
Right.
That's how collaboration works.
But if I were to just really
try to push my agenda on you,
that's the Golden Rule.
So, as you're talking to leaders,
C-Suite executives,
how do you help them cope
with this new era?
Obviously, 2020 gave life
to a lot of issues that are present
not just in United States,
but in the world in general.
The Me too movement
over the past few years,
the Black Lives Matter movement.
So, what's happening now
as you're observing
with the leadership scene?
And what are some practical things
that as a leader myself or
my friends or anybody else
who wants to become a good leader,
what can we do to improve?
So, the first thing is something
that I'm leading by example on, again,
because I firmly believe
and I can prove it,
that people follow what you do,
not what you say.
So, I don't do diversity,
equity and inclusion training anymore.
I'm white and I don't do it.
I refer it to people of color, some women,
some men, but people of color
because it's very hard
to coach or teach anything
where you can't possibly walk
in those shoes.
I mean, look, we're all in the same storm,
but we're definitely in different boats.
And you cannot ever assume
you can relate to someone
or step in their shoes
or be where they've been if you haven't.
And it's a really slippery slope.
So, for leaders in particular,
I had a client this morning say,
"We'd love you to do DE and I work."
And I said,
"No, I'm white. I'm not doing it."
"But here's a couple of people
to choose from. You pick."
"But I love all of them
that I'm referring you to."
And most of these particular leaders
and I'm thinking about recently
are also white.
And it's sometimes a little bit
of an eye opener, they're like,
"But I don't understand?"
"Like you are a coach."
"Why wouldn't you do that work?"
And you're a woman,
it's like I'm a white woman of privilege.
Whether I've earned it or not,
it doesn't matter.
And so, I think it's really time
to really raise this bar.
And that means we have to do something.
And that's my something.
I love it.
That is very very inspiring.
So, I love to spend the last few minutes
that we have to get to know you
a little bit better.
And what really motivates you?
Because over the years,
having done so much and being so in tune
with the things that make you happy
and helping others achieve
that fulfillment and understanding
of where their joy, productivity
and balance in life
So, what are you
really get excited about?
Helping others
that want to change the world.
So that I'm not feeling so much
like I'm doing a lot of this on my own.
It's too slow.
And you also mentioned
that you are a little ADHD with it,
with the fact that
you're a little impatient
to wait for it to happen, right?
Always.
So, how does that come into play?
So, do you work
with a lot of different people
so that you can experience
a lot of different journeys?
And by the time you move on
to the next journey,
the first one will have caught up
and got to work?
That's a great question. Yeah.
There's also a spectrum I've identified.
I've actually have this
self named protocol about how I coach.
There's a guide process
and involve process and a master process.
Because your life is a gem
and it's multifaceted and that's G-E-M.
And some people
pace through the guide piece,
which is training wheels
really really fast.
Others, it can be years.
Some people get through like,
Ah, I'm wobbly,
but the training wheels are off.
That's the evolve process really fast.
Others are years.
Master is,
I'm an autopilot
and I no longer have to think about,
oh, I'm going to turn left
I pushed the blinker down on the car.
And that's where I want everyone to get.
And then they've probably outgrown me
or they can just check in occasionally
for maintenance or whatever.
And I'm cool with that.
And not all coaches are cool with that.
I don't need to coach people for life.
What does that mean to coach?
So, let's go back a little bit
and go up 30,000 feet in the air.
Why do executives and leaders
need a coach?
Because the average person
thinks of a leader, a big time CEO,
we're thinking politicians,
"They have it together."
"They know everything."
"They're moral."
"They know exactly what needs to happen."
But it's not always the case, is it?
No. And it certainly wasn't for me
when I hired my first coach,
which was when I was
helping a founder grow
and exit her business.
Two heads are always better than one.
I've always found that to be true.
No one knows everything about anything.
And the sounding board,
even if you have
a fantastic board of directors,
sometimes you just need to vent.
You need structured venting.
And you need a sounding board
who then may help you
get back to solutions and options.
So, I am an avid believer
and not just because
that's what I do for a living.
I had a very serious coach,
in my last company
before I defected from corporate America.
Is it difficult sometimes for leaders
to hire a coach and to start the process,
feeling that they're maybe giving up
some of that ego or control
that they had before
or they thought they had?
That's a really good question.
Yes. And I'm really clear.
I do what's called a fit call
before I coach anyone.
It has to be mutual.
We have to be on the same page.
And if you're not self-aware
and if you don't want to shift
and you don't want to transform
in an accelerated way,
I am absolutely not the coach for you.
I'm all for healthy ego.
but super inflated ego,
I'm a pretty tough coach with.
I'm pretty good
at getting that back in check.
Fragile ego, I don't coach people
with fragile egos. It's just not my line.
What does that mean fragile ego?
Sometimes it's a victim thing;
it's a super hypercritical thing;
it's poor me,
look what the world's done to me;
but here I am with this pile of money
and our big title,
like, I don't have the patience for it.
Yeah, I'm also a mom.
So, that's the mom card.
I love it.
Okay. Dana, before we leave,
I want to thank you again, first of all,
for being so generous with your time
and being so flexible
with all that's happened.
This is definitely
very very insightful and very interesting
both talking about the work life-balance
and mainly, I'm taking from this
being honest with yourself.
And it's difficult to raise
and especially coming in at Stanford
and in Silicon Valley,
there's so much happening
and there's certainly
different opportunities,
And it's very easy to lose track
that there's only 24 hours in the day
and it might make sense
to even spend
five or six hours of them sleeping.
My girlfriend definitely is, we're having
our daily struggles with that
and she needs to win more often.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself
and why those three words.
You won't be surprised.
Tenacious, impatient
and universally minded.
I love it.
Why those three?
I've always been known
even in my last two companies ago,
Global Group I was running,
they called me "Tenacious D"
because I just will not give up.
I am such a firm believer
that if something needs to be done,
I'll get it done.
It doesn't matter if it's a mountain
that needs to be moved, or a hill.
If I believe it, I'll do it.
If I don't believe it, I also won't do it
as I enter my early 50s here.
I won't do it if I don't believe it.
And that's new for me.
I used to do things
I didn't believe in
because I thought I was holding
the company line or whatever,
but not anymore.
I just will only do what I believe in
and I'm going to do it
with a lot of tenacity.
I love it. And I have other two.
Two more words
that I need explanation for.
Impatience, it's probably the ADD.
It's probably a little bit
of Silicon Valley and also boredom.
Frankly, my mind works fast
and so I get bored
and that's usually not good.
And finally, the last word.
Yeah. Universally minded since I was born.
I mean, as long as I can remember,
I've been crusading,
fighting for the underdog, causes.
Kind of grew up that way in Wisconsin
where I was raised
before I came out here
to the great Bay Area.
And I do believe
that we can make a dent
in the universe
and do good.
I do believe in being socially conscious.
100%. It sounds like
that's exactly what you're doing,
whether it's by helping others
achieve that or by spreading your message.
And I definitely hope
that this will also help
being insightful for others.
It definitely was for me.
Thank you very much again
for being so generous with your time.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Same to you and your listeners.
Thank you.
Take care.